hey what is up guys I'm Kim PhD here and
there are rumors of the next iPhone not
having any headphone jack at all
whatsoever and actually a couple other
phones too but I made a video all about
this initially and it's sort of seesaw
back and forth between yes it will no it
won't yes it will no won't but with the
recent influx of all these lightning
headphones that we're seeing now from
all these manufacturers seems pretty
likely that we're going to see a new
iPhone with no headphone jack so by
getting rid of the headphone jack Apple
kind of gave himself two options with
the built-in headphones that they
included with every iPhone box ever
which would be either make them
lightning headphones now instead of a
regular headphone jack or make them
wireless earbuds or I guess the third
option would be to not include them
anymore but hopefully they don't do that
please don't do that so Bluetooth
headphones can be pretty good but
they're also easier to lose when they're
wireless and they're also a little bit
more expensive so a lot of people see
Apple going with lightning headphones as
their bundle for the next iPhone
assuming it doesn't have a headphone
jack
now our lightning headphones any good
you didn't really know that before but
now there are actually a couple pairs of
lightning headphones out that you can
buy which we did buy and I'll figure it
out so this first pair is the philips
Fidelio or Fidelio or fitzroy Fidelia
but this is pretty much the simplest
implementation you can find so there on
your headphones
pretty simple design they have leather
all around the outside and I guess
plastic everywhere else there's nothing
too flashy about the design but they
look like a normal pair of headphones
and then they connect through the
Lightning port instead of the headphone
jack and since they are lightning
headphones they also have a built-in DAC
so digital analog converter the DAC
itself is actually in the headphones
it's not built into the cable or
anything where you can see it but you
can do that with a digital signal now
since when you go through the Lightning
port you're not relying on the iPhones
built-in DAC anymore you can rely on the
DAC that's built into the headphones to
do all the work they are a little bit
bass heavy but they sound pretty good I
mean there's not a whole lot to complain
about as far as audio quality and they
have a little bit of a volume rocker on
the side to turn the volume up and down
on your iPhone while they're plugged in
as pretty much every other pair of
headphones
ever also has and there's also a giant
play/pause button that is the entire
right hand side of the headphones that's
pretty clean now this pair of headphones
is by Audis and they're called the sign
and they're a big step up the price is
also a big step up but these you can
immediately tell they're a lot heavier
they're immediately a nicer built pair
of headphones so there's metal all
around the hinges are metal the ear cup
holders are metal
everything is all-around well-built and
then you have this sort of a pseudo
leather finish on the backs of the ear
cups which is actually kind of nice to
feel and then a top band is also all
this leather and it's really saw so
there's a really adjustable really
comfortable slightly heavier but also
slightly better built headphones this
one also has a built-in DAC and they put
it right here in the cable so you can
see it same functionality you got the
play/pause controls volume up volume
down a microphone for taking calls etc
and it sort of splits the cable the
lightning cable into two plugs one in
each of the ear cups so this pair of
headphones actually comes with two
different cables one of them is just a
lightning cable so it's a lightning end
on one side and three and a half
millimeter headphone jack and the
built-in DAC but the other cable is just
a regular three-and-a-half millimeter
cable with no built-in Dex so you're
going to be using your phone stats so
because of this we actually get to
directly see or hear the difference the
advantage because this is one of those
big high-end pairs of headphones with
the huge beefy drivers that can't really
be power to their full potential by the
DAC that's in your phone they need some
sort of extra external power so when you
just go in straight with the
three-and-a-half millimeter headphone
jack you're going to notice that and
crank up the volume on your phone all
the way the max and the headphones still
only get up to like a barely decent
volume and everything still sounds kind
of flat and almost a little weak like
you're listening to the music from
behind a thin wall it's clearly
struggling again your laptop your
desktop computer might not have this
problem but when you're on the go most
smartphones will not handle this pair of
headphones very easily some do but most
don't so when you do go in via lightning
you get the bundled in deck built
specifically for these headphones so in
theory they're a perfect fit for it they
have just the right amount of power and
the shape of the sound is exactly the
way the manufacturer wants and you can
definitely hear the difference when you
switch over you get better instrument
separation better volume tighter bass
more pronunciation in the mids and highs
and just overall a much better sound as
you'd expect so the advantage is kind of
real with the lining headphones I mean
just because you get the built-in
custom-built DAC now that so doesn't
answer the question how do you charge
and listen to music at the same time you
would need
I guess wireless headphones to be able
to do that but that's it so far the
thing is with both of these these have
been both pretty premium headphones
meaning expensive so I would be curious
to see what a cheap pair of lightning
earphones or just like a regular pair of
lightning earbuds would look like how
cheap could they possibly be anyway the
iPhone 7 is a few months away we'll get
all the answers soon but until then feel
free to check out I'll have links to the
headphones I've showed in this video
below and of course you should watch the
video all about the possibility of not
having a headphone jack and a phone
below as well all the advantages of
digital versus an analogue connector
worth it definitely watch it that's been
it thank you for watching this video
I'll talk to you guys the next one bass